monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs effectivement
il ne revient ce matin de m'exprimer
devant vous en raison du motif évoqué
par le président larcher
le premier ministre est en effet
susceptible d'être cas contacts et une
je crois qu'une dépêche de l'elysée
vient d'annoncer que le président de la
république avait lui-même été
diagnostiqué positif au coronavirus
permettez moi de commencer cette
intervention en ayant évidemment une
pensée particulière notre pays vous le
savez affronte la pire crise sanitaire
qu'il ait connu depuis un siècle
loin de perdre en intensité le virus
continue à progresser la situation
sanitaire reste évidemment préoccupante
et nous avons atteint depuis une dizaine
de jours un plateau qui se stabilise
malheureusement à un niveau qui ne
permet pas encore de garantir une pleine
maîtrise de la circulation virale et ce
alors même que les fêtes de fin d'année
approchent la deuxième vague n'est pas
derrière nous aussi la prudence et la
vigilance devront rester et de mise
pendant de longues semaines encore
l'arrivée du vaccin et le lancement dans
les toutes prochaines semaines de la
campagne vaccinale dans notre pays
constitue cependant un grand motif
d'espoir le gouvernement a souhaité
venir préciser au parlement les
fondements de notre stratégie vaccinale
ses modalités de mise en oeuvre mais
aussi la façon dont nous l'intégrons à
notre dispositif global de lutte contre
le virus
il est essentiel que nous puissions
ensemble engager un débat constructif
sur ce sujet c'est la raison pour
laquelle au delà de cette séance un
cadre de dialogue pérenne a été installé
avec la mise en place d'un comité
permanent comprenant les présidents de
chacune des assemblées et les présidents
de l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires
comme je le disais l'arrivée du vaccin
est une étape très importante car cela
peut être la solution qui permettra de
protéger durablement la population
française et même la population mondiale
face à ce virus nous l'espérons tous je
sais que ce que nous serons
collectivement à la hauteur
et depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire le sénat a été une force
motrice parce que les territoires les
collectivités territoriales les élus
locaux ont été eux aussi en première
ligne face à la détresse de nos
concitoyens dès le printemps dernier la
france a pris l'initiative d'une task
force européenne capable de constituer
une seule force d'achat de façon à peser
dans les négociations et pour éviter une
compétition nécessairement contre
productive entre les pays européens
aujourd'hui les résultats sont là nous
avons précommander près de 200 millions
de doses permettant de vacciner jusqu'à
100 millions de personnes car la plupart
des vaccins vous le savez exige deux
injections à ce stade les vaccins les
plus avancés sont le vaccin peter b you
in tech et le vaccin moderna d'autres
vaccins se situe en phase iii des essais
cliniques et pourrait être disponible
dans les mois qui viennent
la stratégie vaccinale n'a pas été
construit ex nihilo elle s'appuie sur
les recommandations de la haute autorité
de santé relative à la stratégie de
priorisation des populations à vacciner
contre le coc vide et elle comporte
plusieurs étapes dont la prochaine doit
débuter très prochainement ça a été dit
par le premier ministre hier nous visons
le début des premières vaccinations
d'ici à la fin du mois de décembre
peu de temps après noël en tout cas nous
l'espérons si les avis des autorités
sanitaires indépendante nous y autorise
et avec une je dirais un cadre de
coopération européen dans le démarrage
de cette campagne vaccinale
cette première étape s'est dans les
faits un premier public dont nous savons
qu'il est prioritaire parce qu'il est
plus vulnérable face à la maladie c'est
ce public le plus fragile le plus exposé
je parle bien entendu des personnes
âgées qui vivent en hébergement
collectif que ce soit des ehpad des
résidences services des résidences
seniors des unités de soins de longue
durée hospitalier protéger ces personnes
vulnérables nos aînés en perte
d'autonomie ses protégés aussi
évidemment les femmes et les hommes qui
prennent soin d'eux lorsque eux-mêmes
présente un risque au regard de la
maladie ou par leur âge ou par la
présence d'une co morbidités les
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé à ce stade sont donc de vacciner
tous les soignants de 65 ans ou avec
comorbidités dans ces établissements
des précisions seront fournis par un
avis complémentaire de la has sur les
autres structures qui accueillent des
personnes âgées
sans être spécialisé dans l'accueil des
personnes âgées pourraient également
être concernées par cette première étape
la population dont je viens de parler
concerne environ un million de personnes
1 million de personnes qui aient chiffre
suffisamment éloquent pour rappeler que
nous avons devant nous un très grand
défi à relever cette première étape sera
décisive
mais les personnels des établissements
pour personnes âgées ne seront pas seuls
pour l'affranchir je m'y engage ils
seront informés en avance les ars se
tiendront à leurs côtés pour que
l'approvisionnement se déroule dans les
meilleures conditions
nous les accompagnerons que nous les
accompagnons d'ailleurs déjà avec la
ministre déléguée chargée de l'autonomie
brigitte bourguignon cette étape nous
avons fait aussi un choix qui me paraît
un choix absolument essentiel et que
j'assume pleinement qui est le choix de
l'information claire loyale et
appropriées dont on s'assure qu'elle a
été correctement donner aux personnes
susceptibles d'être vacciné ainsi que le
recueil du consentement de la personne
et si la personne en ehpad n'a pas
suffisamment d'autonomie pour exprimer
clairement son consentement
nous demandons alors aux équipes
soignantes dans les établissements
d'aller rechercher le consentement de la
famille ça prendra forcément un petit
peu de temps chacun peut le comprendre
et nous demanderons nous enverrons une
instruction dès que nous aurons les
recommandations de vaccination à
l'ensemble des directeurs
d'établissement n'a plus de 10000 pour
personnes âgées pour leur demander de
commencer dans des délais évidemment
raisonnable cette consultation est ce
recueil du consentement à travers une
consultation pré vaccinale médicale
c'est-à-dire qu'aucune personne ne se
verra injecter un vaccin en ehpad sans
avoir un été bénéfique à un check up
médical pour vérifier qui a pas de
contre indications éventuelles qu'une
indication d'ailleurs est bien présente
sans avoir été clairement informés et 3
sans qu'on ait recueilli son
consentement
personne ne se verra imposer la
vaccination ni dans les ehpad ni
d'ailleurs partout ailleurs dans le pays
c'est un choix que nous faisons en
france qui n'est pas forcément un choix
qui a été fait partout mais encore une
fois c'est un choix que nous assumons je
suis certain vous y serez sensible
j'aimerais ensuite la deuxième étape de
la vaccination tout cela va dépendre
évidemment du rythme de livraison des
différents vaccins
on a vu d'ailleurs que certains
laboratoires avaient pris du retard
chez ce patient on peut parler de retard
mais n'avait pas réussi à aller au bout
de la phase iii dans les délais qu'ils
espéraient
et en fonction des arrivées des doses de
vaccins nous élargirons progressivement
le public pouvant bénéficier en priorité
la vaccination ce sera en ville que les
choses se passeront en lien direct avec
les médecins traitants avec les
soignants avec l'appui fondamentale des
pharmaciens
cela concernera les personnes âgées de
75 ans et plus cela concernera également
les personnes dans un deuxième temps de
65 ans et plus et ensuite les
professionnels de santé du secteur
sanitaire et médico-social âgé de 50 ans
et plus et ou présentant des
comorbidités après vive et reviendra le
printemps et nous pourrons ensuite
rentré dans une troisième étape de la
vaccination en élargissant
progressivement le public bénéficiaire
de la vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population générale majeur avec une
progressivité ce sera les personnes
âgées de 50 ans et plus
les professionnels des secteurs
essentiels au fonctionnement du pays en
période épidémique dans le domaine de la
sécurité de l'éducation du secteur
alimentaire les personnes vulnérables et
précaires ainsi que les professionnels
qui les prennent en charge les personnes
vivant dans des tentes dans des
hébergements confiné où des lieux clos
puis tout le reste de la population
majeure je vous le disais au j'entends
parfois des questions et qui pourrait
d'ailleurs jouer lever tout de suite
toute incompréhension pourrait être
tentant de se dire pourquoi est-ce qu'en
janvier une personne de 70 ans en ehpad
seraient vaccinés prioritairement par
rapport une personne de 90 ans qui
vivrait la maison
la raison mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
elle nous est donnée par la haute
autorité de santé elle même quand elle
nous dit lorsqu'on est dans un
hébergement collectif avec une centaine
de personnes âgées fragiles et lorsque
le virus entre et nous avons
suffisamment d'expérience et de recul
pour le savoir il va rarement touché une
seule personne il va toucher plusieurs
personnes plusieurs résidants parfois
plusieurs dizaines de résidants et dans
certains établissements on a pu compter
des dizaines de morts donc nous
priorisons d'abord l'hébergement
collectif et ensuite nous pouvons
vacciner en individuel dames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous sommes bel
et bien entrée dans l'organisation de la
campagne vaccinale
c'est une véritable épreuve logistique
temps les échelles sont sans comparaison
avec nos traditions vaccinale la
première étape de la campagne
correspondra à l'utilisation du premier
vaccin mis à disposition le fameux
pfizer bayod ntech sous réserve de
l'obtention évidemment de l'autorisation
européenne de mise sur le marché qui
devrait intervenir le 21 décembre si
tout
si tout se passait bien ensuite il y
aurait un avis la commission européenne
probablement le 23 décembre et ensuite
la qualité le comité technique de la
vaccination de la haute autorité de
santé pourrait donner un avis en france
entre le 24 et le 26 ou 27 décembre nous
permettant alors de commencer sans délai
la campagne vaccinale la haute autorité
de santé précisera les indications les
contre-indications individuelles et
collectives en fonction des données
scientifiques qui lui reviennent parce
que je le dis à ce stade ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui met en
place qui met au point le le vaccin pas
puisqu'ils n'auraient mis en place deux
virus contrairement à ce qu'on peut
parfois lire dans certains réseaux
évidemment et vous le savez ce n'est pas
le gouvernement qui détermine la cible
vaccinale ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui choisit un vaccin plutôt qu'un autre
notre rôle mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est de faire en sorte que
les choses se passent bien
conformément aux données factuelles
éclairé de la science notre objectif
c'est le bon vaccin au bon patient au
bon endroit au bon moment
et c'est cette chaîne logistique
monumental s'agissant du boxeur du
vaccin
pfizer dont je veux vous parler un peu
pourquoi chaîne logistique monumental
parce que c'est un vaccin qui se
conserve à moins 80 degrés et d'ailleurs
je remercie des collectivités qui nous
ont appelé en me disant qu'il disposait
de moyens de stockage à moins 80 degrés
je pense au directeur du port de sète
jean claude gayssot par exemple ou à
d'autres collectivités qui nous ont fait
savoir qu'ils avaient des laboratoires
vétérinaires capable de stocker ces
vaccins en réalité ne suffit pas de
stocker ce vaccin dans un congélateur à
-80 il faut un congélateur qu'ils soient
qualifiés calibré équipe et sécurisé est
doté d'un système d'information en
propre pour être capable de ne jamais
briser la chaîne logistique du froid
ce vaccin de pfizer by one tech il est
composé de ce qu'on appelle des brins
d'arn messager qui sont extrêmement
fragiles extrêmement sensible aux
variations de températures extrêmement
sensible d'ailleurs aux transports à
telle enseigne qu'une fois décongelés
une fois décongelés nous n'avons que
douze heures de transport potentiel
avant de devoir injecter le vaccin sans
quoi les brins d'arn messager pourrait
être abîmé le vaccin serait moins
efficace
vous le voyez on a donc la nécessité de
le conserver a moins 80 degrés dans des
conditions de sécurité
absolument drastiques une fois
décongelés nous avons cinq jours pour
l'administrer au plus tard au patient
éminemment que douze heures de transport
pour pouvoir l'emmener d'un point a à un
point b avec plusieurs étapes que chacun
peut comprendre qu'ils sont des centres
de stockage des pharmacies pour qu'il
puisse être préparée et enfin les
établissements pour qu'il puisse être
offert donner aux patients c'est donc
une contre 1 d'autant plus importante
que je le disais il ya plus de dix mille
sites collectifs de vaccination a
planifié a programmé dans les prochaines
semaines dans notre pays pour relever ce
défi nous avons fait le choix de la
compétence le choix de la connaissance
en nous appuyant sur les pharmaciens sur
les circuits logistiques traditionnel de
transport de médicaments sensibles en
renforçant encore la sécurisation de
toutes les étapes
partout où cela faisait sens je le
disais nous aurons des consultations pré
vaccinale le recueil du consentement
puis viendra le temps de la réalisation
de l'injection de vaccins il y à une
deuxième injection de ce vaccin fire
bayonne tech qui est nécessaire entre 18
et 23 jours après la première
pour que le vaccin soit pleinement
efficace au cours de ce deuxième
injection dans un ehpad certaines
personnes qui n'auraient pas pu être
vacciné la première fois ou qui
n'auraient pas souhaité être vaccinés
qui se verrait maintenant rassuré avec
le recul pourrait bénéficier de la
première injection
au moment même où on ferait la deuxième
injection résidents imposant donc une
troisième venu dans l'établissement pour
pouvoir compléter totalement la campagne
vaccinale
vous comprenez tout ce que cela implique
en termes logistiques pour cela et pour
éclairer le débat et je dirais renforcer
la confiance au delà
au-delà du fait de balayer toutes les
contrevérités qui pourraient se faire
jour çà et là mais je crois que nous
avons là une responsabilité collective
nous avons aussi le devoir d'avoir
d'apporter une information je lisais
claire loyale appropriée c'est ce qu'on
dit en médecine pour que chacun puisse
saisir pleinement les enjeux de cette
vaccination
ce que nous savons à ce stade du vaccin
pfizer bayod ntech et ce que nous ne
savons pas c'est un vaccin issu d'une
start up allemande qui a fait un
partenariat avec un groupe
pharmaceutique américain pour pouvoir
produire plus massivement dans le monde
le site de production des vaccins qui
seront données aux français est situé en
belgique pas très loin de chez nous
c'est donc un vaccin à arn messagers
c'est effectivement une méthode assez
innovante de vaccination qui aura aussi
une portée très forte nous l'espérons à
l'avenir les traitements contre le
cancer
la rn message et c'est comme une petite
partition qui rentre dans la cellule et
qui est traduite en protéines une des
protéines du virus une ou plusieurs
protéines du virus mais certainement par
reconstituer le virus qui permet
d'engager une réaction immunitaire de
sensibiliser les cellules du système
immunitaire
la protéine est ensuite détruites les
brins d'arn messager sont immédiatement
détruit et reste finalement la mémoire
immunitaire qui fait que s'ils
abandonnaient le virus tape à la porte
le système immunitaire le reconnaît
comme un intrus est équipé pour cela et
l'empêchent de rentrée c'est comme ça
que ce mécanisme fonctionne à ce stade
que nous savons c'est que ce vaccin dans
les études ils protègent les cellules
des poumons et c'est important protéger
les poumons puisque les formes graves
qui mène en réanimation sont des formes
pulmonaires et respiratoires très sévère
nous ne savons pas en revanche s'il
protège la muqueuse nasale la muqueuse
oropharyngée
et donc nous ne savons pas si les passes
les personnes doivent quand même être
contaminées avec des formes légères
éventuellement transmettre le virus ne
vont pas assez d'informations nous les
aurons bientôt nous espérons évidemment
cette efficacité
ce sera leur formidable puisque la
grande différence elle se situe ici si
on protège les poumons
il ya une protection individuelle contre
les formes graves mais si on protège
contre l'invasion virale on a non
seulement une protection individuelle
mais on a aussi une protection
collective et là on rentre dans une
dynamique qui serait différente donc sur
la base des données de la science
actuelle vacciner des gens qui se
reportait potentiellement contagieux
pour limiter la contagiosité
c'est trop tôt on ne peut pas le savoir
par contre vacciner des gens qui sont
susceptibles de faire des formes graves
dont des personnes âgées en
établissement collectif ça
ce que nous dit la science ce que nous
donnent les études publiques désormais
transparente analysés par les et par les
enquêtes françaises européennes
mondiales
c'est que ça fonctionne et c'est une
chance et c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire quand j'entends parfois
que on a développé ce vaccin est trop
vite avait pensé à ce film de ma des
housses amadeus sur sur mozart où il ya
cette scène où mozart composé une
partition intimement magnifique je ne
sais plus quelle était cette partition
pardon pour ce trou de mémoire et et où
le roi la cour lui dit c'est beau mais
il ya trop de notes on ne découvre pas
un traitement trop vite c'est une chance
et une opportunité pour la santé des
populations que d'arriver à avoir une
recherche est suffisamment efficaces
pour identifier des traitements des
vaccins qui peuvent sauver des vies dans
des délais extrêmement courts - comme
neurologue qui fait face à des maladies
qui peuvent être redoutables et pour
lesquels parfois on manque de
traitements mais à chaque fois que le
traitement arrive je ne me pose pas la
question de savoir s'il est arrivé trop
vite je me pose la question de savoir
s'il est efficace et si les études
scientifiques peuvent attester du fait
qu'il est sûr et qu'il peut donc
protéger les patients auquel cas c'est
une chance donc je le disais hier à
l'assemblée nationale
la science est magnifique la médecine
est magnifique nous devons le célébrer
et pas en avoir peur mais c'est un
combat je dirais je je dis ça
en présence de la ministre de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal c'est c'est un combat que
nous menons c'est un combat que vous
devez mener avec nous le combat pour la
confiance dans la science la confiance
dans le progrès ça va bien au delà la
question de la vaccination
je reviens à mes moutons la connaissance
et l'information sont des données
absolument essentiel dans la période et
nous appuyons sur les compétences du
professeur alain fischer grand
professeur alain fischer qui est une
personnalité du monde de la médecine a
grandi minogue et qui est indépendant
dans son fonctionnement et qui permet de
relayer des informations qui lui
semblent importantes viendra donc très
prochainement le jour de la vaccination
et alors là il y aura évidemment un
check-up encore une fois sanitaire qui
sera réalisée au pied du lit du malade
de la personne pour vérifier qu'elle
n'est pas malade au moment de la
vacciner il faudra faire attention
évidemment si la personne a présenté de
la fièvre c'est là éventuellement des
symptômes mais admettons que tout se
passe bien
alors là injection vaccinale a lieu
pitre il y aura une surveillance
ensuite qui opérait tout ça sous la
responsabilité médicale et ensuite une
deuxième vaccination trois semaines plus
tard monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez moi
pour conclure de mettre l'accent sur
notre méthode méthode ça vient du grec
meta et au dos qui signifie au dessus
pour meta et le chemin pour au dos au
dessus du chemin
la première balise du chemin que nous
allons suivre c'est celle de la
mobilisation générale
c'est un défi je les dis mais ce n'est
pas le défi du gouvernement c'est un
défi collectif c'est un défi pour la
nation toute entière
c'est le sens même de la tenue de ce
débat devant la représentation nationale
pour surmonter se dessine le
gouvernement n'entend pas travailler
seuls
nous avons souhaité organiser les
comités de suivi hebdomadaire avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes jeu
réunit d'ailleurs toutes les semaines
les représentants des professionnels de
santé les ordres les syndicats au sein
du comité des professions de santé
puisque c'est eux qui seront en première
ligne nous faisons le choix de la
confiance dans les soignants dans les
médecins jamais une campagne de
vaccination n'a toute façon fonctionner
dans notre pays sans impliquer en
première ligne celles et ceux qui
soignent et en qui les français ont
confiance
nous réunissons évidemment les
représentants des fédérations
hospitalières les conférences de
directeurs des présidents de commission
médicale d'établissement
la semaine dernière j'ai réuni près de
vingt mille médecins lors d'une visio
conférence d'une heure
libéraux et hospitaliers pour échanger à
bâtons rompus pendant plus d'une heure
je le disais sur la vaccination et ses
enjeux le gilles bourguignon réunit très
régulièrement l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde médico-social
parce que c'est pour eux aussi un
challenge énorme vous l'imaginez
organisé on la période des fêtes une
consultation au sein des établissements
recueillir le consentement tout mettre
en place pour que quand on en voit et
qu'on amène les vaccins tout soit prêt
pour pouvoir protéger les personnes je
vous le dis sans ambages je ne crois pas
que nous pourrons créer l'adhésion des
français sur la vaccination et vous
savez combien nos concitoyens sont
exigeants sur ce sujet sont nous appuyer
sur les communautés médicales
paramédicales et scientifique mais je
sais aussi que sont les élus locaux en
l'occurrence on serait plutôt peu de
chose je tiens donc un comité des élus
tous les quinze jours qui permet de
partager toutes les informations
d'associer pleinement les collectivités
au déploiement de notre stratégie
qu'il s'agisse de s'appuyer sur leur
connaissance fine des territoires sur
les ressources dont il dispose
ou simplement sur la confiance et la
dite l'adhésion dont disposent les élus
locaux
vous le savez les collectivités
territoriales en main dans la main avec
les agences régionales de santé les
préfectures un rôle majeur à jouer dans
cette campagne de vaccination dès la
première étape et plus encore pour les
suivantes
je réunissais ya quelques jours les
représentants de la mf de l'adf de la
rnt de france urbaine
alors oui et d'ailleurs les relations
sont tous je vais dire au beau fixe ça
fait du bien et je les remercie
d'ailleurs de leur communication
positive à l'égard de cette consultation
que nous menons à leurs côtés et quand
ils me disent comment est ce qu'on peut
vous
il ya beaucoup de moyens pour les
collectivités territoriales de nous
aider à la phase de la vaccination dans
les ehpad c'est peut-être mettre à
disposition des ressources sanitaires
dont elles peuvent disposer pour aller
prêter main-forte notamment pour les
ehpad et territoires reculés et imaginez
quand on va commencer à vacciner en
ville des personnes âgées dans un grand
nombre d'entre elles peuvent être isolés
que ce soit en territoire urbain parfois
en quartiers prioritaires de la ville où
les ressources médicales sont plus rares
il va pouvoir il va falloir les
identifier et qui d'autre que le maire
que le ccs que les associations locales
pour savoir sur la base notamment de
l'enseignement de la canicule qui lie à
peut-être madame je ne sais comment âgé
de 85 ans qui vit tout seul
à trois kilomètres du bourg et qu' elle
n'aura pas la démarche forcément d'aller
faire vacciner et qu'il fallait
al'inverse chez elle cette démarche dû
aller vers qui est essentiel et par
ailleurs lorsque nous vaccinerons
population générale certains élus auront
peut-être à coeur de mettre à
disposition des locaux non pas des
immenses vaccinodromes je n'y crois pas
mais des petits centres de vaccination
pour permettre aux médecins et aux
infirmiers que celles offertes aux
pharmaciens de se retrouver et de faire
venir directement les patients pour être
plus efficace encore et renforcer la
confiance la confiance est encore la
confiance
le gouvernement aussi saisi le comble
conseil économique social et
environnemental de façon à ce qu'il
mette en place un collectif de citoyens
chargés d'émettre ses observations et de
formuler des recommandations sur la
politique conduite
enfin puisque j'ai parlé de mobilisation
générale je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer
la coordination européenne qui a marqué
ces dernières semaines je dis ça devant
clément bonne en charge des affaires
européennes et qui ne ménage pas ses
efforts depuis des mois pour tenir cette
cohésion européenne si essentiel que ce
soit dans la chatte dose avec une
espagnole une hache et que ce soit dans
la mise en place ce programme
opérationnel de vaccination je dois le
dire l'europe s'est montrée en la
matière unis elle s'est montré soudé
elle s'est montrée ambitieuse pour
préparer de manière efficace et à grande
échelle cette campagne vaccinale
historique avec mes homologues allemands
belges espagnols italiens luxembourgeois
néerlandais mais également suisse nous
avons échangé avant-hier dans un esprit
constructif et solidaire
nous avons convenu qu effectivement au
toujours pour renforcer la confiance et
parce que ça fait sens nous voulions
coordonnées le début le lancement de ces
campagnes vaccinales
monsieur le président madame
messieurs les sénateurs nous sommes à
l'aube d'un vrai changement de braquet
dans notre lutte contre l'épidémie
pour voir pour en venir à bout il faudra
de la patience il faudra de la
transparence il faudra je le redis de la
confiance c'est à ce prix est à ce prix
seul que l'espoir enfin sera permis je
vous remercie
merci
[Musique]